ah run run run
markiplier is coming for you not yet in
20 seconds oh my god i'm coming for you
oh no
i'm coming for you baby where are you is
one of your bananas
can you see me no i saw a way
where are you so
funny wait something's just going on
with your internet i don't know
what's happening but you need let's just
not fix it let's just play like this
oh switch to spec now you know i want to
watch this bob anyway huh huh
okay you're you're around here aren't
you you don't know where i am
you're around here i see you you oh yes
you can that's a lie
you're a lying liar and i'm gonna
confirm you are you it are you inside
the house is that where you are
uh no are you you better light it up
mark
are you [ __ ] with me yeah
what does that mean what what i don't
know
what are you talking about i'm just
putting all the options on the table
are you in here you're in here aren't
you
you're in here it's getting boring mark
you better floor it
you you're in here
where are you let's just say mark i've
got this one in the chest
that doesn't work at all that doesn't
even remotely work wait
it's a pretty accurate picture where
what the hell
wait am i leaving here i haven't seen
you a single time i have no idea what
you're up to
oh oh okay i was in the wrong unless
you're digging with me still
i would never do such a thing sir never
oh never wait how's my alignment do i
look natural
i'm looking through the same perspective
you are so i can't tell
you can hit the space bar and you can
like run around or fly around or
whatever
i can't oh wow i can where what the heck
um wade give me a hint help me out here
come on buddy pal
you look pretty good if you are what i
think you well you're sideways
how about now
no the funny part is you didn't move on
my screen
oh man mark just appeared i really
thought you were in the market
i literally did not see you a single
moment ever
oh why is it so dark oh yeah we're
hunters now
i'm so glad you're my teammate wade
who isn't the game starts what's this
game
what are we playing yeah wade you're
just a delight to play with
and i hope you win a million dollars
i hate the sarcasm
i genuinely want you to win even though
you're not mark it's probably like a
teacup
in like in the spawn no i'm big i'm so
big
no way no i'm big i'm dead serious i'm
not lying this time
okay this time i'm not lying this time i
lie a lot
but not this time where are you guys uh
you didn't see anything did you see
something i think i saw a movement
you didn't see anything where where'd it
go wade you didn't see anything
movement was on top of a balcony
don't forget about your grenade don't
forget about your grenades
damn it god damn did you know or were
you just gonna stare i didn't know what
you were
i literally just saw a movement oh my
eye i thought you saw me
and you're just [ __ ] with me i didn't
know that you were a barrel
i thought maybe you were because i
thought there was a barrel missing from
one of the areas
see i'm used to playing with like scene
anders
or mangamix and they they will oh they
no
they know but i can mess with you guys
right they play this that often
oh they played a lot god they played
this dean anderson have been playing it
for like
years oh no wow come on
i might have just accidentally cheated
myself into a pretty awesome spot
really tell me more
i can't no no no i'll i'll give you uh
i'll give you a chance i'll give you a
chance
wait is that you no no no no come here
and come here come here no no no don't
run for me
don't run away come on i just want to
say hi how're you going hey
what did you do oh come back here
oh it's a flying bicycle
oh come back please
it won't let me pick anything what
you're just being bad
god put your reticle like right on it or
right over it or right around it or
somewhere
well now you have to find me mark oh wow
oh i'll find you oh is it bad is it bad
i want to say before this all unfolds
this was an accidental spot i got stuck
here i can't even believe you're there
so we're clear where is am i going to be
running around this map for like an
hour i hope so well the game's only
three minutes and 20 seconds more so
you're running around for an hour i see
you mark i see you running up inside
there
what what what are you talking about i'm
not there i'm not i don't actually see
you anymore
i don't know what you're talking about
oh i see you in the window
where up up up oh
i close i i you're you're behind a wall
right now
yeah you're over there i see you up on
top of that
auba warm bunny rabbit follow me mark
where
where i am
i thought you were like up there or
something like no i just got stuck in a
hole
oh okay all right i got ya
darkness
what the hell my name is billy scooby
dude
oh give me your best bane like give me
your best bane impression
very best bob first what what is
honestly i've only seen that movie once
i saw it in theaters yeah
what does he even say i don't remember
he's like
receiving darkness is your ally
does he say something about no one
knowing me until they put on this mask
yeah they didn't know who i was until i
put on the mask
which is weird because it hit my
identity
but i don't know what his voice is going
to do
i don't know what i don't i don't know
what he says
how do i not know this i watched that
movie it was it's been a while since i
watched it was one of those movies that
i really enjoyed but i didn't watch
twice
darkness is your ally i think ark's a
glass bottle i just saw him
the darkness is your ally no you're like
you think we're just talking
about what i sound like it don't sound
british okay
alley hang on i'm gonna i'm gonna
actually try because i used to be able
to no
buddy no something about a mask are you
gonna sing something nobody knows
the trouble i've seen batman
and then i just lost you i lost you yeah
i saw him he was a little glass bottle
no
no i wasn't i saw bob and i thought he
would have run across bob's path but
you think the darkness is your ally oh
that doesn't count using your hands i
can hear you
just damn it well what else am i
supposed to use i'm
gonna get a referee fine you know what
screw you guys i'm just hiding
where are you i don't even know where
you are i'm looking around for you guys
okay that's like baloney
that's below no i'm that serious i
haven't followed me around
oh that's serious who's that gloria
who's that who's that
who's that who's that no no
no no no no no no no
damn it it's you're not as good at that
as it sounds like you are
it's just never look around correctly
if i don't see you i look like a [ __ ]
but if i see you
yeah yeah i still look like a [ __ ] yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
oh are there any really hilarious props
can i become like a door or something
i wish you mean like an iron door
i want to be the bottom half of an iron
door
your wish is minecraft's command
batman that's not that's not that's that
guy
that's not bad at all okay now
hunters have been released where are you
wade balls
i am on a balcony i think
someone disturbed watermelons someone
did what with what the what with the
water but
someone disturbed the watermelon
disturbed any watermelons
you think the watermelod is your ally
that's a bit fruity
why are you leaving my spot man
i'm just kidding what what no
i knew i wanted to mess with watermelon
whatever i play as a prop i always move
everything i see
you know that that's i wish i had a
screen cap
it's actually pretty smart it is a
grounded break thing
it's a good one it's a good strategy to
just dick with people by mass ending up
with everything
hey wayne bob's in a good spot i'm
coming after you hi mark
where are you so we're clear mark your
crotch was right by me for a long time
i knew you were there he could feel you
are you wow
you think the balcony is your ally
god dangerous come back to the market
what are you doing man i'm trying to
find
wade yeah yeah i'm gonna be a son of a
[ __ ]
wow
where are you see ya there's one
there you go i'm going back to the
market see ya
don't dick with me this has to be so
boring to watch
you're a liar it's so much harder for
you when i move around
i know this game used to be a barrel of
fun
you used to be just like you did my
thing well when you were killing wade i
was a bicycle and i was running around
because i could see you not going back
to the market so i went out there to try
and become like one of those orange
things
uh-huh yeah what didn't work whatever i
just care if you believe me it's it's
equally fun for me either way
well i'm glad you're enjoying it
you'll never find me was that your
grenade already wade
no i was just switched like i pulled my
gun out oh
come on bring it on
should i kill you mark or should i just
let you keep playing for a while
you wait what do you do do you see me
i don't know do i see you no baby i
don't know
maybe yeah
where'd you go mark nowhere and
everywhere
wait remember he's running outside
you can't hit me oh god damn it damn you
guys to hell oh you're burning
your bottle like every time shut up i
didn't i
i was doing i was i was gonna elude you
did you see me bob
no oh okay i was trying to get you to
run oh
okay of course i didn't see you stop
[ __ ]
so uh where are you guys now following
you around
really yep
i know i'm just jogging along is that a
clue
that's not nice wade
where are you i have no idea where he is
yeah mark
where is you i don't know where are you
he's um he's uh just taking in uh
he's uh he's uh
fruit hi buddy
that's so not even close mark shut up
and
shut your face let me do my thing do
your thing
let me do my thing do your thing do it
yeah
peace
i know you weren't even hiding
once you've been playing it for about
four hours